안녕하세요. 시도에어입니다. 올해
날씨는 유독 좀
희한합니다. 지난달엔 이게 4월
날씨야 하는 추위였다면 요즘은 하루
안에도 여러 계절이 공존나는
느낌이에요. 아무튼 확실한 건
그럼에도 여름이 오고 있다는 느낌이
든다는 겁니다. 저는 몇 차례 얘기한
적 있지만 개인적으로 여름을 그렇게
좋아하진 않습니다. 제가 땀이 많은
것도 있지만 여름이 특히 옷을
다양하게 입기 어려우니까요. 오늘은
그래도 여름에 입을 만한 다체로운
색감의 옷들을 소개해 보려 합니다.
물론 이렇게 입어도 덥긴
하겠지만요. 처음 소개해 드릴 옷은
굿폭스의 반팔 크루넥 니트입니다.
굿폭스는 서촌에 위치한 바보샵의 P비
브랜드예요. 개인적으로 서울내에서
어느 한 지역에 가면 방문하게 되는
매장들이 꼭 있습니다. 가령
한강진에는
르메르와 매클레즈가 있다면 서촌에는
샵 아모멘토, 팔머, 그리고 바보샵이
있습니다. 바보샵은 클래식한 복식부터
이와 귀엽게 붙일 수 있는 다양한
액세사리 등이 많습니다. 그래서 보고
입어보는 재미가 있어요.이 이
바보샵에서 만든 굿폭스는 스웨트류부터
니트, 셔츠 그리고 아우터까지 평시에
입기 좋은 옷들을 만드는
브랜드입니다. 저도 사실 잘 알지는
못했는데 작년에 혼자 서촌을
배회하다가 우연히 알게 됐어요.이
제품을 구매할 때 기억을 되짚어
보자면 당시에 얇은 반팔 니트를
굉장히 갖고 싶었습니다. 정피의
제품이요. 그런데 그런 반팔니트를
찾으려고 검색하면 항상 여자옷만
뜨더라고요. 확실히 반팔이니트가 남성
복식보다는 여성 복식에서 주로 나와서
그런지 제가 원하는 스타일의 제품을
찾기가 어려웠습니다. 그런 와중에이
제품을 서촌에서 운좋게 발견했고 여러
색감 중 계절감에 생각해서 쨍한
녹색을 구매하게 됐습니다. 저는
봄여름의 초록색 상이와 청바지 조합을
꽤나 선호합니다. 제 입으로 말하긴
좀 뭐하지만 뭔가 사람이 되게 산뜻해
보이지 않나요?
아무튼이 제품은 사실 단품으로도
있지만 어 레이어링 용도로도
활용합니다. 회색 맨투맨 같은 것
안에다가 이런 얇은 소재의 니트를
깔아주면 살짝살짝 보여 가지고
포인트로 좋더라고요. 흰색 티셔츠
등을 입어 줘도 좋지만 이런 색채가
도드라지는 제품도 레이어링해 주면
색다르니까 한번 시도해 보시는 걸
추천드립니다. 두 번째로 소개해 드릴
제품은 코틀의 리베인 리버시브
재켓입니다.이 코틀이라는 브랜드는
맥클레에서 이번 시즌부터 바잉을
시작했습니다. 제가 타이가
타카아시와를 보러 갔다가 직원분께이
브랜드에 대한 얘기를 듣고 구매까지
하게 됐습니다.이 이 브랜드의 옷과
철학이 꽤나 마음에 들어서 제
예감으로는 아마이 브랜드는 제가
꾸준히 찾아보고 입지 않을까 합니다.
코틀은 일본 오카야마에서
2015년도에 시작된 비교적 신생
브랜드입니다. 디자이너 와타나베
토시아키가 설립한이 브랜드는 생활을
위한 유니폼이라는 철학을 바탕으로
일상 속에서 자연스럽게 녹아들고 오래
함께할 수 있는 옷을 제작합니다.이
이 브랜드의 가장 뛰어난 점은 바로
원단과 염색 기법인데요. 코틀은
일본의 여러 직물 업체와 협력해서
꾸준하게 새로운 컬렉션을 개발한다고
합니다. 그리고 간물, 먹물, 천연
인디고와 같은 자연 소재를 활용한
전통 염색 기법을 선보이고 있습니다.
제가 구매한 코틀의이 제품의 이름은
리베인이라는 말이 들어가 있는데요.이
리베인 컬렉션은 코틀의 하이엔드
라인입니다. 저는 사실이 염색 기법에
매료돼서 구매하게 됐어요. 자세히
보면 이름처럼 인맥라인 같은 구조를
표현한 염색 기법을 사용했습니다.이
염색에 들어간 인맥 모양이 저는 너무
신기하고
새롭더라고요. 실크, 햄프, 유기농
초장면 혼방으로 이루어진 소재에
인디고 염색 중 가장 오래된 방식인
쪽잎과 êm물을 활용한 염색 기법을
사용합니다. 옷을 잘 아시는 분들은
다른 곳에서 봤을지도 모르지만 제가
여러 인디고 염색을 경험했음에도 이런
형태는 또 처음 보더라고요. 천연
염색이라 염색이 일정하지 않은데 그
부분도 개인적으로 마음에 들었습니다.
그뿐만 아니라 넥라인 주변론 인맥을
표현한 핸드 스티칭이 들어가 있어요.
리버시블이라 양쪽으로 입을 수 있는데
포켓과 넥라인, 단추 모양 정도의
차이가 있습니다. 그리고 양면 단추에
하나씩 깨진 자기가 들어가 있어요.
멀리서 봤을 땐 그저 평범한 인디고
자켓일 수 있지만 이렇게 하나씩
들여다 보면 참 매력 있는
제품입니다.이 제품은 소재가 얇아서
봄여름에 에어컨 바람 때문에 들고
다니는 가디건처럼 활용하기 좋습니다.
그리고 곁에 나갔을 때 햇빛이
반사되면이 인맥 모양이 좀 더
두드러지고 더 시원한 색감이
표현됩니다. 독특한 인디고의
색감이라서 청바지나 치우 팬츠
어디에나 잘 어울리긴 하겠지만 저는
개인적으로 청바지와의 조합이 마음에
들더라고요. 한 여름에는 당연히
어렵겠지만 초여름까지는 얇은 흰티
위에 걸쳐서 자주 입고 다닐
계획입니다. 다음은 erl의 링어
티셔츠입니다. 제가 여름에 단품으로
입기 좋아하는 티셔츠를 하나만 꼽아
보자면 저는 링어 티셔츠를
고르겠습니다. 이유가 두 가지가
있는데 먼저 정핏으로 입기에 좋은
디자인이에요. 소매를 딱 잡아주는 링
덕분에 넉넉하게 입기보단 딱 맞게
입었을 때 예뻐서 제가 좋아하는
봄여름의 반팔실루엣이 나옵니다.
그리고 제가 프린팅에 들어간 티셔츠를
엄청 선호하는 편은 아니지만 왠지
모르게 링어 티셔츠는 프린팅이랑 잘
어울리더라고요. 제가 재작년부터
여름에 잘 입고 다닌 제품 중 하나가
바로 태켓의 링어 티셔츠였는데요.
태켓 제품은 처음 사 봤었는데 가격
대비 퀄리티도 괜찮고 의미가 크게
없는 프린팅이긴 하지만 그래도 너무
귀여워서 두 번의 여름 동안 열심히
입었습니다. 그리고 두 번째로 드린
잉어 티셔츠가 바로 이l의
제품입니다. 제가 쨍한 색을 좋아하긴
하지만 사실이 노란색이 좋아하는만큼
여러 개 사기에는 좀 부담스럽긴
하잖아요. 그래도 하나는 이번 여름에
입어보고 싶어서 고민하다가 구매하게
됐습니다. 이래 제품도 이번에 처음
구매해 봤는데 생각보다 면소재가
굉장히 좋습니다. 엄청 말랑말랑한
느낌의 면이라서 계속 만지게
되더라고요. 브랜드를 그래도 한 번은
짚어
보자면이 LA에서 시작됐다 보니까
귀여운 문구나 파판 느낌의 색감을
사용하는 등 개성이
두드러집니다. 그래서 예전부터 언젠가
이래를 산다면 좀 잘 입을 수 있대이
아래스러운 색감 하나를 옷장에 드리고
싶다는 생각을 했습니다. 그런
점에서이 티셔츠는 잘 구매하긴 한 거
같은데 잘 입을 수 있을지는
지켜봐야겠습니다.이 티셔츠는 제
기준에서 봤을 때 좀 요란한
편입니다. 일단 색감도 강하고 거기다
문구도 꽤나 크게 써 있으니까요.
그래서이 티셔츠를 입을 때는 목걸이를
하거나 팔찌를 하거나 뭘 더
추가한다기보다는 그냥 청바지 하나에
입어 주는게 저는 개인적으로 제일
좋더라고요.
괜히 여기에 또 색깔 맞춘다고
자크미스 팀브랜드 이런 거 신어
주기보다는 청바지에 로퍼 같은 거
하나 신어 주면 전체적인 무게감이
균형잡히지 않을까
생각합니다. 하나 주의할 점이
있다면이 아래 티셔츠는 정말 적게
나옵니다. 아마 브랜드에서 추구하는
실로 때문일 텐데 제가 입은이
티셔츠가 제일 큰
사이즈인엑라지예요. 이건 그래서
애석하게도 덩치가 좀 있는 분들이라면
조금 어려움이 있을
듯합니다. 프린팅에 있는 옷을 거의
처음 말씀드린 김에 제가 그냥 또
자랑하고 싶은 티셔츠를 하나 짧게
소개해 보려 합니다. 바로 잔나비
콘서트 굿즈로 나온 티셔츠인데요.
최근에 제가 잔나비 콘서트를
다녀왔습니다. 제가 경험했던 콘서트
중에서이 가수의 노력을 단연 최고로
느낄 수 있었던 공연이었어요.
잔나비의 최정훈 씨가이 셔츠에 수트를
입고 나왔는데 한네 곡쯤 불렀을
때부터 수트까지 다 땀으로 젖어
있었습니다. 보면서 정말 진심으로
저러다 기절하는 건 아닌가 할
정도여서 공연 자체도 굉장히 굉장히
인상적이었지만 그 태도가 너무 감명
깊었습니다. 아무튼 여러모로 너무
좋아서 공연 끝나고 나오면서 굿즈를
구매했어요.
검정과 하얀색 중 저는이 하얀색을
골랐습니다. 대부분의 저라면 안전한
검정색을 선택할 텐데 검정은 프린팅의
흑백으로 나온 반면에 하얀색은이
프린팅의 색감이 잘 드러나서 너무
귀엽더라고요.
콘서트의 제목이 적힌 티셔츠라서 또
언제 구매할 수 있을지 몰라 열심히
입고 또 소장하고자 후다닥
구매했습니다. 마지막으로 소개해 드릴
제품은 꼼데가 블랙라인의 비대칭
반팔셔츠입니다. 이건 제목과 달리 좀
칙칙한 색감이긴 하지만 보너스
개념으로 소개해 보려 합니다. 사실
너무 마음에 드는 제품이라서 그냥
소개하고 싶었어요.
꼼데가 블랙의 캐리오버 제품으로 알고
있는데 실제로 매번 나오는지는 잘
모르겠습니다. 아무튼이 셔츠가 마음에
들었던 건 당연하게도이 비대칭 버튼
구조 때문인데요. 정말 한 끝 차이의
단순한 변주인데 인호로도 단품으로도
다 활용하기 너무 좋더라고요.
단품으로 입으면이 하나의 특징으로
꼼대가송이라는게 느껴지고 그렇다고
개성이 너무 튀어나가지도 않아요.
날이 좀 추울 때 니트 같은 것에
레어링하거나 카라가 없는 재켓 안에
입어주면 그 나름대로 존재감에 표현할
수 있을 것 같습니다. 그리고
검정색이라 더 보이긴 하지만 두께도
하늘하늘해서 여름에 충분히 잘 입을
수 있는 셔츠입니다.이 이 제품은
꼼데가 구조적인 패턴의 바지와 함께
입으면 그 매력이 배가 되겠지만 저는
잔잔하게 입는 걸 좀 더 선호해서
그냥 일자 와이드핏의 슬렉스와 붙여
봤습니다. 첫 눈길에는 무난하지만
나름의 변주가 있는 반팔 셔츠를
찾으시는 분들에게는 좋은 선택지가 될
것 같습니다. 지난주 제가
탱고로스고뭐 청담에 남아 있던 걸 본
기억이 있는데 한번 가서 입어 보셔도
좋을 것
같습니다. 올해 반환점이 보이는이
시점에 다들 어떻게 잘 지내고 계신지
모르겠습니다. 저는 올해 공연을 많이
다녀왔고 또 많이 갈
예정입니다. 올해초 검정치마부터
시작해서 코헤드 플레이
그리고 잔나비 거기다 최근에 한스
짓까지
운 좋해도 올해 제가 가고 싶었던
공연들이 정말 많이 열렸어요. 아직
예매해 둔 큰 공연들이 좀 남아
있는데 당장 다음 콘서트는 아마
이시바시 에이코 님의 라이브 공연이
될 것 같습니다. 이시바시 에이코
님은 드라이브 마이크 영화의 사운드
트랙을 작업한 것으로 유명한 분인데
제가 하마구치 류스케 감독의 영화들을
인상깊게 봐서 한번 이것도 경험해
보려고 합니다. 주변에 이분을 아는
사람이 없어서 혼자 가는데 잔잔한 걸
좋아하신다면 한 번쯤
추천드립니다. 아무쪼록 들쑥날쑥한
날씨 속에서 건강 잘 챙기시고
문화예술도 경험하면서 행복도 챙기시는
계절이 되었으면 합니다. 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다. 감사합니다.